The sun is around 4.5 billion years old, and
just like you and I, it's aging.
In just over a billion years, the sun will
have expanded so much that the heat will begin
to melt the earth's surface.
So, is there any way us Earthlings can avoid
this detrimental event?
Can we save ourselves from the suns ultimate
death?
Sure, none of us will be here, assuming we
don't find the secret to everlasting life.
But, at the billion year mark, the sun will
have used up the hydrogen fuel in its core,
forcing it to burn at its surface.
The increased radiation will boil away all
of the water on Earth creating an international
desert.
Flash forward about 5 billion years, and the
swelling sun will begin literally melting
mountains, with most, if not all life on earth
now extinct.
Around 7.5 billion years, the expanding sun
- now a Red Giant - will engulf the Earth
entirely.
Sounds bleak -- so can we avoid this hot mess?
It turns out; our best bet lies in something
called "Gravity Assist".
A technique we've been using for years, only
to launch space crafts throughout our solar
system.
Anytime a spacecraft or satellite comes in
close proximity to a planet, gravity grabs
hold.
And if the spacecraft arrives at the perfect
angle, it's able to use some of the planets
velocity to catapult it further into space.
This 'extra' energy comes from the planet's
own energy of motion around the sun.
But, as Newton famously said "To every action,
there is an equal and opposite reaction".
As the spacecraft uses the Earths gravity
to speed up and move towards Earth, the planet
will ever so slightly slow down and move towards
the spacecraft.
Of course, the spacecraft's mass is so small,
comparatively, that it gets launched incredibly
far, while the planet experiences little change.
But, if we were to increase the spacecraft's
size -- or use an asteroid -- we could potentially
move the Earth's orbit away from the sun.
This would take millions of years, and involve
large objects coming just close enough to
not collide with Earth, but hey, we've got
a billion year head start!
It may seem far-fetched, but it's already
happening!
On October 9th, 2013, Earth will be used to
gravity assist a spacecraft called Juno, which
is on its way to Jupiter.
As Juno flies within 559 kilometers of us,
it will use Earth's gravity as a slingshot
to boost its velocity by 7.3 km/s; Meanwhile,
Earth will have been moved by a fraction.
Juno will later arrive at Jupiter, in 2016,
where it will study the interior of the planet
and help to unveil many new spectacular mysteries
of our Solar System.
In order to move the Earth within our billion
year timeline, we would need approximately
1 encounter every 6,000 years, using an object
with a mass of approximately 10^19kg.
That's 19 zeros - somewhere around the size
of a 100 km-wide asteroid.
In between passes, the asteroid would slingshot
around the sun, fly out to Jupiter, and then
be gravity assisted back to Earth - like one
long version of catch between planets.
Over millions of years, this would move Earth
to a comfortable 225 million kilometer orbit
out from the sun.
And while it is feasible, even with today's
technology, it doesn't come without risks.
For one, we may lose the moon, which could
ultimately create some extreme weather patterns.
Not to mention, the Earth's spin may increase,
making days only hours long.
The surrounding planets, like our new neighbor
Mars, would likely have their own orbits destabilized.
And...you know...the asteroid could come plummeting
into Earth by accident.
But, perhaps these are the risks we need to
take to give our descendants, the planet and
all life on it a few extra billion years.
Got a burning question you want answered?
Ask it in the comments, or on Facebook and
Twitter.
And if you want to learn more about Juno?
Check out its awesome interactive website
we have linked in the description.
Special thanks to NASA for inspiring and supporting
this episode, and subscribe for more weekly
science videos.